[Musik]
der reinhardswald in nordhessen sommer
2009 10 sowie hier sieht der wald an
vielen orten in deutschland aus dürre
stürme und borkenkäfer setzen den bäumen
zu
förster rufen den notstand aus weit mehr
als 100.000 hektar forst sind zerstört
mehr als die landesfläche berlin
betroffen sind vor allem wirtschafts
forste monokulturen mit fichten oder
kiefern naturnahe wälder mit alten
laubbäumen vor allem buchen werden immer
weiter zurückgedrängt
so alt wie hier im lübecker stadtwald
werden sie kaum noch irgendwo in seiner
zeit als forstdirektor gestaltete lutz
heese eine naturnahe waldwirtschaft in
deutschland ist das selten sie wirklich
mittelalten und alten bäume die den
ökologischen wert ausmachen und die
wirklich die ganze breite des ökosystems
zeigen die sind weitestgehend
verschwunden wie sie haben nur noch
junge mittelalte wälder die ökologisch
nicht sehr hochwertig sind
feser fordert mehr wildnis im wald natur
brauche alle altersphasen denn viele
arten sind auf alte bäume und totholz
als lebensraum angewiesen naturwälder
auch die bundesregierung hat dieses ziel
ausgegeben
2007 beschloss sie die nationale
biodiversitätsstrategie mehr
artenvielfalt durch weniger
forstwirtschaft die bundesregierung
unterstützt das 45 prozent unserer
wälder bis zum jahre 2020 sich völlig
frei entwickeln lassen das heißt dass
daraus wieder wildnis wird
doch die bundesregierung ist gescheitert
die forstwirtschaft tut sich schwer
damit auf einnahmen zu verzichten und
wehrt sich häufig gegen eine nutzungs
stock statt fünf gibt es derzeit in
deutschland gerade mal 2,8 prozent natur
wald
das ist für mich auch ein schreck
gewesen ehrlich gesagt dass man also
wälder zwar romantisch schön findet aber
in dem moment wo man etwas dafür
einsetzen muss als sie ihn schützen muss
immer vom geld spricht und sagt ja da
geht uns ja eine produktionsfläche fälle
dabei ist die hälfte der wälder in
öffentlicher hand würden zehn prozent
davon nicht mehr genutzt ließe sich das
fünf prozent ziel erreichen
die öffentlichen wälder sind allein aus
den gesetzen heraus und aus
rechtsprechung heraus verpflichtet nicht
in erster linie geld zu erwirtschaften
sondern der daseinsvorsorge und der
funktionsfähigkeit des naturschutzes zu
dealen
genau das will ja letztendlich dieses
programm warum klappt es trotzdem nicht
nachfrage beim wichtigsten forst berater
der bundesregierung
jedes land macht eigentlich das was es
für richtig hält und es hat eine zeit
lang gedauert bis man die länder davon
überzeugt hat mittlerweile ist es so
dass wir in fast allen bundesländern die
landesgelder wirklich zehn prozent aus
der nutzung genommen haben und der
eigendynamik überlassen
wie weit sind die bundesländer wittlich
wie viel wald wird der natur überlassen
frontal 21 hat nachgefragt das ergebnis
ernüchternd nur drei länder haben das 5
prozent natur wahlziel erreicht
mecklenburg vorpommern schleswig
holstein und thüringen
alle anderen länder liegen darunter
bayern das mit abstand waldreichste
bundesland hat das 5 prozent ziel gar
nicht erst übernommen
hier dürfen sich nur 1,3 prozent des
waldes natürlich entwickeln dabei
gehören dem freistaat besonders
hochwertige laubwälder der steigerwald
in franken der buchenbestand gilt als
einer der wertvollsten in deutschland
doch der steigerwald ist keine wildnis
er wird wirtschaftlich genutzt diese
männer kämpfen dagegen sie wollen mehr
naturwald georg sperber übernahm 1972
das zuständige forstamt und wollte nicht
sowie seine vorgesetzten
da lief gerade die planung fürs nächste
jahrzehnt und das war eindeutig weiter
runter mit den alten buchenbestände zwar
flächig ich habe es nicht gemacht aber
meine vorgänger hatten das natürlich wir
haben sie sind weisungsgebunden gemacht
und da hat dann eine katastrophe nach
der anderen zugeschnappt
das weiß ich noch auf viele alte buchen
stehen nun auch deshalb weil sperber um
sie gekämpft hat mitten im steigerwald
liegt ein naturwaldreservat eine kleine
fläche auf der die bewirtschaftung ruht
hier darf sich seit mehr als 40 jahren
ein natur wald entwickeln umgefallene
bäume bleiben liegen
totholz ein existenziell wichtiger
lebensraum für viele tierarten wo man
eben sie dass es hier richtig brummt
also die sind tot dieser lebensraum
sondern da brummt das leben sieht man an
den vielen specht einschlägen die hier
überall sind da das heißt hier kommen
die spechte her und suchen nach laufen
bei den pilzen ist es so der
zunderschwamm wird allein von über 20
käferarten besiegelt die nur in dem es
unter schwarz sich entwickeln das heißt
wenn dieser pilz mal fehlt habe ich
diese ganze arten kette nicht wenn wir
uns anschauen arten wie käfer die am
toten holz leben fledermäuse die in den
wäldern leben oder vögel die in alten
wäldern leben die stehen alle auf der
roten liste ganz ganz weit oben und die
sind hoch gefährdet weil es eben diese
alten wälder nicht mehr gibt
deshalb wurde hier 2014 ein schutzgebiet
eingerichtet
der hohe buchenwald er verband zwei
kleine naturwaldreservate mit 775 hektar
umfasste er ganze 0,6 prozent des
naturpark steigerwald
das entspricht nur 0,1 prozent der
landeswald fläche dennoch klagten die
bayerischen staatsforsten wegen der
einnahmeausfälle
am ende wurde der schutzstatus wieder
aufgehoben jetzt soll der wald wieder in
den mittelpunkt rücken seit november
regiert die csu in bayern in einer
koalition mit den freien wählern und der
ministerpräsident hat den wald für sich
entdeckt als teil einer neuen
klimaschutzpolitik die neue
herausforderung ist dass der klimawandel
den prozess der veränderung der wälder
voranbringt und da müssen wir eine
reaktion zeigen deswegen wenn wir neue
bäume insgesamt 30 millionen bäume in
den nächsten fünf jahren ansiedeln
das singende gewaltforschung stärken wir
waren einige alte flächen wenn wir all
die fragen wenn wir behutsamer behandeln
an anderen stellen müssen wir uns
moderne entwickeln und was das
allerwichtigste ist
wir verändern das grundprinzip des
staats fast das ziel ist nicht ihn als
wirtschaftswald zu sehen sondern als
klima watt noch wird abgeholzt
im vergangenen winter im steigerwald
alte stark buchen für ex förster georg
sperber völlig widersinnig erst recht
wenn politiker den deutschen wald für
klimaschutz und artenvielfalt retten
wollen ich würde ja politik empfehlen
solange die entwicklung so dramatisch
verläuft wie sie derzeit abläuft den
einschlag in natürlichen naturnahen
stabilen wäldern würde ich die nicht
anrühren
es sollen zu wachsen es soll in
kunststoff bayern den worten des
ministerpräsidenten müssen noch taten
folgen die zahlen seiner regierung
zeigen nur 1,3 prozent der waldflächen
in bayern sind naturwald baden
württemberg landkreis waldshut
kaputte wälder das ruft politiker auf
den plan
pressetermin mitten im wald der grüne
ministerpräsident pflanzt eine buche und
verspricht den wald zu erhalten für ein
besseres klima es geht voran nur mich
vielleicht nicht schnell genug
ich lerne gerade vor wenigen jahren
nationalpark ausgewiesen
es gibt bahnen welt da nicht das wissen
wir sicher vermehrt machen wir brauchen
ja auch die erfahrung aus welt die wir
nicht bewirtschaften wie entwickeln die
sich der 2013 ausgewiesene nationalpark
ist in wirklichkeit naturschutz im
kleinformat
das winzige schutzgebiet liegt im
naturpark schwarzwald und umfasst
bezogen auf die waldfläche baden
württembergs gerade mal 0,7 prozent die
naturbelassene kern zone sogar nur 0,24
prozent insgesamt können sich in baden
württemberg nur zwei prozent der wälder
natürlich entwickeln
damit ist das grün schwarz regierte land
nach bayern schlusslicht der zuständige
forstminister von der cdu hat damit
offenbar kein problem
er will keine weiteren wälder sich
selbst überlassen
ich bin angesichts der waldschäden
derzeit gegen das ziel diese wälder
stillzulegen weil wir schnell
produktionsflächen brauchen um
kunststoff zu speichern und nicht
produktionsflächen brauchen um den
verrotten zu lassen und so pflanzt der
minister eine douglasie der schnell
wachsenden nadelbaum angeblich ein
alleskönner holzlieferant und
klimaretter mit natur wald und wildnis
hat das nichts zu tun dass fünf prozent
ziel ist in weiter ferne